je n'ai jamais voulu remonter moyens qui
sont les nôtres
[Musique]
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais
demandez fois vous soyez à quelle heure
à quelle heure sa dépendance et de 17h à
manon ma carrière comme ça je crache sur
le règlement soit pas prêt de voir
aboutir à lui un parcours arrêts de jeu
mais quel succès mais tu tiens là j'ai
un truc on peut enfin la scène de la
zone euro cet appel dès samedi soir le
jour bonjour madame
nota les vaux bien waouh quel gros party
c'est carrément un arrondissement et
saint patrick
temis pas de calais si mu pas de câlins
et pourtant ils sont là
[Musique]
bah
alors il avait la laponie j'ai aimé j'ai
adoré j'ai tous d'origine vin rouge l'as
et j'ai adoré noël j'avais le chalet
restaurant
[Musique]
non